welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of House of
the Dragon episode 5 where the green
wedding ends with a white knight cap and
a series of fumbles by losing it on the
sidelines
as always this episode was filled with
subtle visual details and deeper layers
of meaning so let's break down
everything you might have missed the
opening credit sequence continues to
evolve slightly Episode by episode this
week the bloodline that branches forth
from Allison's dial compared to the
single Branch last week now splits into
two branches Allison does have multiple
children currently aegon and Helena and
soon more kids like Eamonn and then
Darren next week when this show jumps
ahead 10 years we will meet some of
these the episode opens at runestone the
home of house Royce in the veil of Aaron
where we finally meet Ria Royce AKA
Damon's wife whom he has called his
bronze which now we see is for her
literal bronze armor Royce's armor is
stamped with runes AKA runestone to mark
their descendancy from the first men to
get these specific runes the customer
pulled them directly from the Codex
runicus an animal skin manuscript from
the year 1300 one of the oldest and best
preserved texts of scallion law scalian
referring to an old dialect from
present-day Swedish her cousins sir
Gerald Royce carries a unique sword now
depending on Gerald's relationship with
the family this may be the Valerian
steel sword of house Roy's lamentation
which does play an important role in the
hands of Sir Willem Royce in the coming
civil war the Royce house words are we
remember so what Damon does may come
back to haunt him Gerald asks what's
today's Quarry rabbit dear
fine challenge so Ria is on a stag hunt
just like viserys and Rainier were but
instead of a white heart she finds a
white fart blocking her path Demon's
hooded appearance makes him look like
the stranger who represents death and
gets a shout out at the end of this
episode Ria says we'll have you at last
come to consummate our marriage the veil
shape might be willing even if I'm not
our sheep are prettier after all so word
travels fast from Damon's line in a
small council meeting in episode one in
the veil Minister said to sheep instead
of women I can assure you the Sheep are
prettier now thanks to vesi for
sponsoring this video House of the
Dragon makes it perfectly clear that
being a Targaryen ain't all it's cracked
up to be yeah there's dragons but
there's also a lot of betrayal and
Intrigue and pretty intense battles and
like gross sex look if it were me and if
I was gonna be sloshing through the
battlefield drench or the blood of my
enemies I'd rather be certain that my
feet stay dry so I would rather be
wearing my vessies Bessie is here to
keep you looking good while keeping your
feet dry besties are the perfect
everyday shoe they're sustainably made
knit sneakers that are 100 waterproof
they are made with this diamond text
material that's super easy to clean with
just a rinse of water no I spilled water
all over my pizza my Oinky oinkies are
bone dry like the densies thanks Messi
so if the weather is wet or if it's
muddy besties can help you besties are
my go-to shoes by my door check them out
in the link below for a pair of your own
Bessie shoes Damon Spooks this horse and
it's almost by chance at Rhea's fall
paralyzes her later on Raines justifies
this by saying the gods are cool the
gods and the humans who act like they're
Gods now there's only one quick mention
of Ria's death in the text of Fire and
Blood there came a tragic mishap of the
sort that shapes the destiny of Kingdoms
the bronze Burr of runestone Lady Ria
Royce thou former horse whilst Hawking
and cracked her skull upon a stone
showrunner Ryan condo interpreted that
to mean Damon must have murdered her
though we still do not see the actual
death on screen and notice that Damon
does not say a single word in this
sequence just as he didn't say anything
in the final sequence of episode three
like then it remains a mystery what his
true motives are and not saying anything
makes him even deadlier in a weird way
but Rhea does kind of invite this
killing I knew you couldn't finish a
knowing jab at Damon's impotency the man
truly does have a problem finishing now
by the way if the shooting location
looks familiar it is the same pass in
Derbyshire in England where they shot
The Princess Bride scene where the
princess and Wesley roll down the hill
again on viserys the ship we follow a
close-up of the royal puke bucket which
viserys waves off but then wretches
anyway Lionel strong we learn has been
promoted for a master of laws to hand to
the king and like all hands of the king
the hand wipes viserys's body has sort
of become a Harbinger for the health of
the entire realm like he has contained
all the rod inside of his body up until
this point yet when he dies you know
that brought it's gonna spread to
everyone
Otto hightower's men depart King's land
be marked with the Hightower Sigil of a
watchtower despite the rain Otto ditches
The Carriage to just set out on
Horseback I assume to put on a dramatic
show after getting sacked fine I'll
leave and I'll get myself pneumonia
you'll notice Otto's saddle shows the
Watchtower Beacon burning green which
gets explained later this episode the
beacon on the high tower
do you know what color it glows when Old
Town calls its Banners To
walk green green fire almost certainly
means Wildfire which the maesters of The
Citadel in Old Town likely would have
helped craft brew the Old Town leaders
to give their calls to war a unique
verdigree now I may be wrong but in the
text house Hightower sigil description I
don't think ever mentions the flame
being green it's just kind of a
watchtower with a flame but of course
Allison's green dress is a hugely
significant gesture that goes on to
Define this whole faction in the coming
civil war the Hightower is considered
the greens because of this moment but
this show goes further to retcon the
color green as part of her family war
cry before that so now this is really
Allison deliberately siding with house
Hightower against House Targaryen and it
could be that seeing the green flame on
her father's saddle as it left King's
Landing could have inspired that choice
Otto warns his daughter a different era
succeeds in war will follow do you
understand
the realm will not accept her and to
secure her claim she'll have to put your
children to the sword she'll have no
choice yeah the way Rhys iPhone's growls
War hairs with the torch fire behind
them so that it looks like he is
breathing fire into his daughter with
this advice this episode's title is we
like the way the words of house
Hightower words that do not get
explicitly spoken this episode only
implicitly with fashion choices and here
in this moment Otto instilling in his
daughter that beacon-esque leadership on
driftmark viserys's Carriage approaches
the valarian castle high tide rolling
down this paved Causeway this Causeway
win at his high tide is the only way you
can reach that castle and notice how the
castle roofs are beaten silver in order
to shine in the Sun and make this Castle
easier to locate from Dragon back up in
the air viserys arrives to find Lenor
and Joffrey lawnmuth sparring in the
yard but no Corliss to greet him lyanna
shows up and says Corliss is in the Hall
of nine named for the treasures Corliss
is acquired over his nine voyages inside
these helmeted skulls are on display
play and it looks like there are exactly
nine of them maybe trophy skulls of a
pirate that cordless kills on each of
those voyages I would say they could be
his ancestors but no the valerians bury
their dead rulers at Sea now the music
underneath all this at least evokes it's
always summer Under the Sea AKA
shireen's song the creepy song that
Stannis baratheon's daughter heard from
the patchface boy on Dragonstone back in
book two of Clash of Kings many believe
this song's cryptic lyrics predicted
events to come in A Song of Ice and Fire
and the traumatized patch face boy
saying these words to creepily talk
about when he nearly drowned this song's
context and its connection with prophecy
makes it perfect music for viserys here
a wannabe Prophet feeling like he is
being dragged into the depths of the sea
much like his doomed Kingdom of valyria
was back in the godswood of the red keep
Lara strong greets Allison novelist
rare bloom
indigenous to Bravos Yeah by All Rights
it shouldn't be thriving here
nature
such mystery a compliment to Allison
does an outsider thriving in the red
keep Hubert Hightower actually later
Echoes this metaphor I worried that
given leave of your father's Shadow you
might Wither in King's Landing son
but you stood tall but hot guys
hilarious spilled some tea the grand
Masters delivered a tea to the
princesses
tea yes and We Know lyrics loves to goss
because in episode 3 he voluntarily
joined the women in the tent to be part
of that tea party now along with that
row of skulls and corliss's throne room
we see that he has his own dollhouse
model the way viserys does of Illyria
his collections also include the mask of
kragus the crab feeder which one of the
directors confirmed to me was inspired
by the mask of the sons of the heartbeat
rainiest arrives and grabs viserys's
rotting hand causing him to wince Eve
best does a great job showing some
Mental Math of how long Leonor and
raniera would have to Wed in bed before
a succession crisis created by viserys
death would kick in viserys allows any
kids born of renera and Leonor to Bear
the name of valerion upon birth at first
but he says the firstborn must take the
name Targaryen when they ascend to the
Iron Throne which Corliss and renice
agreed to probably because they know
viserys will be dead at that point and
they'll have more freedom to sway what
name the new monarch takes rhaenyra and
Leonor speaking code about their
appetites in rhemara proses that they
marry but with a discreetly open
relationship after rainis returns from
viserys she washes her hands something
not commonly done in this whole
unsanitary world but it signals that she
totally senses his coming death rattle
loud and clear and Randy's warns that
Bloodshed is inevitable knives will come
out but her her husband and for their
heirs remember Otto similarly warned
Allison that children would be put to
the sword but rainy says knives not
swords as her concern is that young
princes and princesses won't be attacked
by Soldiers with swords necessarily but
perhaps a more treacherous more intimate
attack as gets into that in the trailer
footage for this season but coreless
reasons our house controls the Rams Navy
e and half its dragons so far the series
has shown us the dragons of Cyrax and
caraxis and one scene of sea smoke also
a new drag in this episode but overall
it's just a reminder that the valerians
control half of the overall Dragon power
in Westeros leonor's lover is Joffrey
AKA The Knight of kisses seen at his
side during the stepstones war council
in episode 3 he says think of the
tournament with the feasts the battles
at Sea his mention of the tournament
alerts some book readers because Environ
blood it's at the tourney when Kristen
attacks shopry so this show totally
surprises Us by moving it up to the
pre-whiting Beast sir Kristen approaches
Rainier on the sail back with his armor
removed as renyra did to him that first
night they hooked up he mentioned
support of sunspear with ships filled
with oranges and cinnamon heading to
essos sunspears the seed of Dorne at the
southern tip of Westeros but rhaenyra
turns down Christian's proposal to run
away with him I am the crown
Justin
the iron throwing moons larger than me
know larger than anyone in my family
like in the Conqueror United Seven
Kingdoms and put them on a path which is
interesting because Renee used to be a
girl eager to flee responsibility and
eat lemon cakes for the rest of her life
but now she mentions aegon the Conqueror
suggesting viserys's lectures about
aegon's Song of Ice and Fire inscribed
into the dagger have sobered her to the
weight of her Duty Allison summons sir
Kristen to ask if there was some truth
to Rainier and Damon but sir Christian
dull confesses to sleeping with her
himself I would ask only this
rather than gelding me and having me
tortured you would sentence me massively
to death despite the text of this moment
focused on Kristen's willingness to die
we focused on Allison's face actress
Emily Carey conveying her betrayal that
Ranier would lie to her in the godswood
remember rhaenyra swore on her mother's
Soul over that in viserys's chamber
there's some close-ups of old valyria
model we see that City surrounding
viserys as he lies gasping weakly
sinking into his chair as if he is
sinking with that Kingdom into the sea
the younger maester Orwell says if I'm a
grand maester I took the liberty of
preparing a fresh set of purple
poultices that might be more
effective that will not be necessary or
a while the leachings have always
brought his grace relief but Melos
denies an alternative herbal remedy
instead preparing these medieval
leechings just another example of the
maesters of Old Town accelerating the
King's death either by incompetence or
by Design viserys speculates on how he
will be remembered since he never fought
or conquered or suffered a defeat it
hardly makes a good shot
we sound good feet 100 years
500. by wondering what kind of man he'd
become had he been tested in a crucible
viserys unwittedly makes an argument in
favor of living one's life removed from
the concern of Legacy that if people
tell stories about your life a hundred
years from now it really means that your
life was filled with drama and if you're
a ruler a lot of people likely suffered
as a result of that drama there's just
something to be said for living a boring
life yet as viserys falls asleep in the
milk of the poppy we cross dissolve into
the clouds and Dragons it's almost as if
viserys is drifting into another Dragon
dream and that is one way he will be
remembered viserys the dreamer it was
his dreams and his indecision over what
they meant that really best defines his
legacy we see these two dragons soaring
toward King Landing land horse dragon
sea smoke we met in episode three and
this new one this is raynice's Dragon
melees a sea dragon with Scarlet scales
and pink membranes on the wings but also
they added streaks of gold as if to show
how the queen Who Never Was deserves a
Golden Crown but never received one sir
Harold westerlane announces the wedding
in attendees starting with the
Lannisters Jason linster leading that
group and his brother Thailand minister
to his side Jefferson Hall plays both of
these brothers and you can see how they
use VFX to double his face and map it on
to Thailand renera with rubies in her
hair finds a way to insult Jason's Pride
thank you Lou Jason I could think of no
better man than Selena
sir Gerald Royce Cuts in front of the
high Towers but both are cut off by the
arrival of the valarians as laying our
steps forward there is a shot from the
throne's point of view showing sir
Kristen in the bottom right hand corner
throwing his head back in agony and
frustration then Damon crashes the party
and right after visery signals for a new
seat to be added the shot frames
rhaenyra to be perfectly lined up with
the Iron Throne as if to say through
Damon will ultimately be her path to
acquiring and securing that Throne also
notice that at the end of the table
Damon now places directly across from
Lena so these two are seated directly
looking at each other able to make eyes
then Allison interrupts The King's
Speech with her show-stopping arrival
wearing Hightower green and while most
see this as scandalous the guests from
house Hightower immediately stand up
proud Hoover with a wide grin actually
when Allison first stood in that doorway
she now most aligned with the Iron
Throne showing how for her this has
heard her most Regal and while everyone
in this Hall stands for the queen Damon
remains seated the whole time even as
she passes by viserys continues with the
speech how he hopes to us her in a
second age dragons which gets a round of
applause but notably not from baymen to
valarian that's corliss's brother who
argued against Damon's Dragon tactics in
episode 3 and not from Hobart Hightower
who is the Lord of all Town only has a
begrudging respect for Dragon power in
Westeros as they dance the bride and
groom say I was never much of a dancer
it's not much different to combat I
shall hope for a different outcome
foreshadowing the way this wedding dance
will transform into bloody combat but
also following the motif of a dance of
the Dragons which is the term or the
Civil War as hober tells Allison that
hold down stands with her in the bottom
left corner you can see Damon staring
daggers into her back sir Gerald
approaches Damon to accuse him of
killing Ria but Damon says he plans to
petition Lady Jane Aaron for his
inheritance of runestone Lady Jane love
an important role to play in the
upcoming conflict Damon and leina make
eyes at each other and meet on the Dance
Floor has anybody ever told you you're
nearly as pretty as your brother Leona's
gold necklace pattern looks a lot like
the interlocking Circles of the necklace
that Damon gave Ranier in I'm pretty
sure that's by Design Joffrey lawnmount
deduces from Kristen's longing stairs
that he must be Rainier a side piece and
he tells him that we should swear to
each other to God then and their secrets
because if those are kept safe
and so we all
[Music]
so what just happened in this close-up
was it Joffrey passing Too Close
requiring Kristen to move his sword did
Joffrey brushed his hand past Chris's
ton in a suggestive manner to try to
close off the loose ends up the square
sir Harwin break bone strong tries to
dance with renira but Damon Cuts in but
Damon and Ranier are now openly
challenge each other in Valyrian a
language that you gotta imagine at least
some of the Valerian cousins will know
they're doing this in plain sight of
everyone even viserys spots them through
the crowd when Damon forcefully grabs
her head before they disappear behind
all the other dancers this episode then
pulls an awesome bait and switch with
the sudden screams which we assume at
first come from renera or a woman
watching something horrible happening to
her but nope it is Sir Kristen going ape
[ __ ] on the night of kisses again in the
text this fight takes place in the
tournament days after this when Kristen
hits Joffrey in the helm with Morning
Star and puts him in a coma for six days
until he dies the fact that it happens
here isn't just a surprise to book
readers it's a stain on the wedding of
Ranier and Lenor in Bloodshed between
nights and early factions of the Civil
War lion all strong wordlessly signals
to brake bones to go retrieve renera and
Brake modes plows through this crowd
ultimately throwing Rainier over his
shoulder and rushes her out you could
also read this as a non-verbal go-ahead
from Lord strong for his son to make a
move on this princess in other ways at
least that might be how brake bones
interpret it Kristen caves in Joffrey's
face and we won't show you but we can't
show you this woman behind sir Kristen
who upon looking at John's face nearly
faints and Lenor Reveals His True
affections and his response to Joffrey
[Music]
yeah notice Joffrey's hand totally moved
on its own there so the guy may still be
alive at least barely for this final
moment or maybe it's just rigor mortis
either way the name Joffrey will remain
important to Leonor for years to come so
instead of a wedding ceremony seven days
after this viserys decides to move it up
to that night before the mess is even
cleared you may be reacting to the
nosebleed you got during this couple not
sure whether he has hours to live or not
so the septum praise
of a warrior Smith
Maiden Chrome
stranger yes he's gonna his Warrior Is
Spoken right over the shot of Sir
Kristen unsheathing his sword in the
godswood making this both a wedding
prayer and a funeral prayer but Alison
stops sir Kristen from killing himself
though you'll notice Allison also
appears at Rainier's side during the
wedding vows so even though the editing
makes it seem like it's happening at the
same time this moment the godswood must
have happened before the ceremony and
Allison has already forged a new
relationship with sir Kristen before
that wedding scene and done so behind
we're near his back the king collapses
again and as they attend a viserys
Joffrey's blood remains pulled up on the
floor in the foreground and a rat crawls
up to slurp it up a vampire rat I guess
because it's ignoring the bounties of
food on all the tables still remember we
saw rats in the red keep last episode in
the teeth of balerion skull and on the
bedpost looking down at Allison and like
those rats this rat represents the rot
that is now spreading and spreading in
this house like the rat in the final
shot of Martin scorsese's The Departed
this world does not really belong to the
living ultimately but to the Scavengers
who have to pick up the pieces after
these self-interested a-holes kill each
other off you can follow me on Tick Tock
Instagram and Twitter at avos follow new
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]